MICHEL DEGRAFF: So one of
the major goals of the course
is for-- because we all speak
a language, or sometimes
many languages.
And what the students
get to understand
at the end of the courses
is that we all hold dear
to an attitude about language.
And some of the
attitudes are positive,
for us and for others.
But oftentimes-- and this
is actually one of the major
issues that we discuss
throughout the course,
is that--
sometimes we have
attitudes that have
a negative impact, severe
negative impact, on the lives
of other people, the life of
sometimes entire communities
and nations.
So I hope throughout that,
students can actually
take this theory that
is in the course,
and see ways in which
they can apply it
to themselves, to
their communities,
to their countries.
So clearly, the case that
I have in mind the most
is my own Haiti, where
attitudes about language
have been one of the
engines that have really
gone against the interests
of most Haitians,
that have allowed a few
to keep the majority,
and the oppression.
But then-- this is true
also for the communities.
So I was very pleased to
see that the students took
that objective very
dearly, and including
some who, in the
course of this class,
have applied what
they've learned,
and taking it outside,
including volunteering in, say,
the dual language program
that just started in Boston.
It's a dual language
program promoting
the use of books in
Creole and English,
and where students are
immersed from kindergarten
in both Creole and English.
And now there's a student who
took that class, my class,
and was volunteering in that
classroom-- for Kindergarteners
who were learning in
Creole and in English.
And to me, that's a
dream because it's
one case where what
you learn in the course
can be directly applied in
the real world context, which
can make actual positive change
in the lives of these children.